qu'est ce qui s'est passé ensuite c'est
vrai que voilà peut-être c'est toi qui a
voulu arrêter la chanson dont n'a pas
arrêté du tout pas du tout non
je me suis je me suis mis à bosser créé
à faire des concerts dans le monde
entier ce qui a pas que la france
d'accord mais parce que c'est une
musique la world music on exporte dans
le monde entier et voilà mais c'est vrai
que ça m'avait acheté gt gt gt pas très
bien à un moment donné je pense que ça a
été un cumul de beaucoup de choses mais
c'est vrai beaucoup de gens sont restés
figés sur la sarkozie en fait vous voyez
comme que comme le soutient nicolas
cervenak soyez brut comme le petit
prince du raï mais avec compléter et
nicolas sarkozy donc après une fois
qu'ils étaient lus que tu as eu des
idées nous souhaiterions de quoi lui
donner un coup de fil ah ouais du tout
ou alors il était bien il était
président il faut lui poser la question
mais je veux dire foden on a bien rigolé
on a fait mon faye est assez terrain
maintenant un j'ai du travail je suis
président mais c est donc et a essayé de
joindre vous et non pas du tout non mais
puisque je suis pas comme ça non non
c'est vrai t'as envie de le revoir ou
pas la vérité non non à la connerie
n'est pas là mais était pressenti pour
être ministre non plus donc du boulot
voilà c'est vrai qu'après quand tu es
président c'est pas pareil aussi mais il
ya eu un mort c'est mathias aussi qu'a
eu ce problème avec quoi enrico macias
pareil qui s'était affichée ouais on lui
en a voulu aussi les méthodes lagarde
ici après mois par rapport à ça j'ai
envie de dire c'est un choix personnel
après les gens il choisit ce qu'ils
veulent ils soutiennent qu'ils veulent
la moindre aide je peux pas interdire à
des gens de choisir telle personne tout
ce qu'elle est de gauche parce qu'elle
est de droite ou parce qu'elle est du
milieu ou fin c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin
de viviez quelqu'un après la question
qu'on peut se poser la jet c est ce qu
il faut
quand on a personnage public s'afficher
aux côtés d'un d'un personnage politique
c'est vrai que ça n'a jamais porté
chance à tout ce que je dis non mais je
pense que j'ai dû donner beaucoup de
beaucoup de gens par rapport à moi ne
sont sont complètement rsa car c'est que
maintenant il ya la jurisprudence faudel
il ya plein de mecs qui t'as vu ce qui
est arrivé à paris avec de mauvais goût
d'ailleurs
najet oui je voulais c'est quelque chose
par rapport à ça par rapport à ce que tu
disais faudel vous dites à un gros cône
en faux pas s'afficher tout ça et nous
en france on dit soi disant faut en a le
droit d'expression la liberté tout ça en
vrai c'est pas parce que tu dis ce que
je pense et que tu fais des choix des
juges et quoi qu'il arrive je tiens
beaucoup
mais jeudi à beaucoup d'artistes faux
cul aussi la vérité sont tous de droite
et ils te disent la gauche la gauche
mais hors antenne la vérité on ne citera
personnes